ein tragödie am wochenende in thüringen
ein notruf bei der feuerwehr geht ein in
trafford flammen schlagen aus einer
wohnung es ist die wohnung von
feuerwehrmann
marcel f mit seiner frau nadine und
ihrem gemeinsamen baby lieben tragisches
familiendrama in thüringen bei
feuerwehrmann marcel f aus treffurt
brannte die eigene wohnung seine ehefrau
nadine kam dabei ums leben
am freitagabend um 20 uhr 8 ging bei der
feuerwehr trafford ein alarm ein
flammen schlagen aus einer wohnung in
der straße des friedens
es ist die gemeinsame wohnung des
35-jährigen feuerwehrmannes marcel f
seiner 34-jährigen frau nadine und ihres
babys levin das im märz geboren wurde
nadines 31 jährige schwester berichtet
bild dass nadine nachdem sie den brand
bemerkte das baby zu einer nachbarin in
den ersten stock gebracht hat danach
soll sie in die brennende wohnung
zurückgegangen sein was ihr zum
verhängnis wurde
sie konnte von den rettungskräften nur
noch tot geborgen werden
nadine f lernte feuerwehrmann muscle
2018 kennen
anfang 2009 10 zogen sie zusammen im
august 2020 heiraten sie marcel krug an
diesem tag stolz seine feuerwehr uniform
jetzt ist feuerwehrmann marcel f
vorübergehend bei seinen eltern in
treffurt untergebracht ganz treffend
trägt trauer
die stadt hat ein spendenkonto für die
familie eingerichtet
mehr nachrichten und breaking news nur
bei bate schau dich hier das nächste
video an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren